no i do not like gavin newsom i do not
take it away some at all in fact i think
um
i would submit that single parents in
california get less money for food from
the government than he spends on his
daily moisturizing treatments
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
new york times best-selling author a
global activist and a destroyer of bad
people rose mcgowan finally welcome to
the reuben report finally dave rubin and
so we meet
hello destroyer destroyer of bad people
i felt that sort of
captured your essence how do you feel
about that i think that's right on
target there was somebody right after um
because i started going after governor
cuomo about last january right away on
behalf of lindsey boylan
and someone on twitter what the day he
resigned he
wrote someone wrote on twitter a woman
god help you if rose mcgowan comes after
you and i'm like finally someone
recognizes me christ how many times i
have to tell these people like i mean
what i say
you have seriously destroyed some people
some pretty awful people and we'll get
to some of that stuff and you know i
want to talk about some new stuff with
you too but i've just learned something
about you in the last couple days that
we've been chatting that uh you're a
larry elder gal and i'm a larry elder
guy
here we are
talk to me yeah i was that weird uh i
don't know if i might have been the only
performer in california ever under
contract to paramount studios or viacom
that would leave set and listen to am
640 larry elder after that would be john
and ken sometimes if i got really riled
up i would pull over on the way home
i always use the name tracy i tried to
find the most basic name i could find
because my voice was somewhat
recognizable so i was like rose
obviously that's and i want i would
literally call and go off on the the
teachers union of california or l.a or
like the vice you know the why is the
state legislature one full calendar year
because it used to only be six months
for the state legislature that they got
paid and then they're like well we can
achieve more if you pay us for a whole
year but yeah you only work for six
months if
so yeah so you you you actually used a
fake name and we're calling into larry
elder show over the years yes
and were you i mean i don't consider you
conservative and i know the labels all
sort of mean nothing and especially for
someone like you the idea of putting you
in a box is kind of nuts but like do you
so i mean do you sort of consider
yourself conservative now or
libertarianish or no like what
smart intelligent
like not dumb and logical
unless
nobody seems to like to listen to that
labels to me i mean if you flip things
all the time like the other night
someone is yelling at me and like i'm
trying to sleep and i was like
congratulations i am trying to stay
awake
or you know you just i like flipping the
language so like what literally the
etymology of language is something that
fascinates me so if we took conservative
and if you take the word liberal both
now have like a because they've been
slimed and smeared in and weaponized
right aggressively weaponized against
each other and against humans all over
the world but if you look at the
definition of both they're quite
beautiful
and both are valid and both can co-exist
so like
you know
libservative i don't know i don't know
that's not pretty i'll come up with
something better but i really think just
by taking the power out of what
something traditionally means i mean it
was all invented at one point anyway
well you know that jordan peterson guy
that i toured with was always talking
about that healthy tension between
conservative and liberal that that's
what you want if in a if you're going to
be in a sane society
i don't know about a say in society
because i think that's still very
limited i think like there's only two
options at that point if you have only
two options ever and there's no other
choice i mean i think the biggest thing
that you know i would like to run on if
i ever run for anything if they can make
it so i don't have to live in the us but
can be a political figure there i'll do
it
but yeah you're not thrilled with the
u.s these days huh
i guess that throws 11. we'll put a pin
in that we'll go back to it all right
but you know the thing is it's like um
the largest voting block i'm pretty sure
is the non-voter
who's representing them
maybe me
rose mcgowan
non-voters from another country
yeah i have a podcast i'm doing um i've
recorded four episodes so far definitely
not normal i guess according to podcast
standards the the first one the engineer
is like okay begin and i'm like [ __ ]
what now and i smoke a bowl in the uh i
take a toke into the microphone exhale
and then just free form
and
who knows what comes out but it weirdly
works i think so one of the episodes is
about um
the fact that
we are constantly talking about the
voters in the media in the us especially
and all over but the people that are not
the voters so why aren't we talking to
them why aren't we analyzing that we
know why because they're only given two
choices and it's it's clearly not
working and as many alcoholics who go to
aaa know the definition of insanity is
uh doing the same thing and expecting
different results
yeah we're quite good at that in the
united states uh let's back up though
for a second to this elder situation
because i'm i'm pretty amazed that you
were calling in like i can just sort of
picture you on mulholland
like they got to go into the archives
and find some of these things but it's
not just that that you like larry and
you like what's going on with his
campaign and we got a couple days left
to save this freaking state uh you
really do not like gavin newsom right
no i do not like gavin newsom i do not
take it away at all in fact i think um
i would submit that single parents in
california get less money for food from
the government than he spends on his
daily moisturizing treatments
and i i think that goes you know that
sounds like a little zinger but no it
really goes to show what these people
prioritize okay who they really are
i was in california when he was
lieutenant governor i've been there you
know i was living there for a long time
when he was like desperately trying to
be governor and it's like dude you look
like guido junior from a movie what are
you doing like you're not the man and
you're live well he looks like the guy
from american psycho well i think he's
liv he's the guy he's christian bale an
american psycho fairly sure that he did
some like a deep fake ai where he stuck
his face on christian bales in the
shower scene and probably also
masturbates to that on the loop just
saying
can you say that on your show
you can say that on my show we have no
rules here
so it's not so much that i love larry
elder because some things we i you know
no like there's you know certain things
that i'm not as conservative on or i
don't even like that word like i said
but they're square
square okay square i'm a little bit more
like i like weirdos i like tiny
adventures i like seeing where the night
goes hey
but
i also like his mind i like his
dedication i love his passion i love the
fact that he is a true patriot what we
need is patriots what we need are
patriots i am a patriot you are a
patriot anybody can be a patriot the
non-voter can be a patriot gavin newsom
not a patriot
there now you see when i flash anger
people always think i'm like that all
the time it's like a thunder cloud and
then i'm back to me what i had to do
yeah and that was that was hopeful not
anger thank you that's what i think
people always say angry and i'm like
passionate and like and and i feel like
i'm like
like the cheerleader like come on we can
do this people got this
rise up you know what's been happening
to you you know what the truth is stop
suspecting it and go into the fact that
it is a fact okay let's operate from a
point of fact at this point not that i
get so many people most especially
american media likes to do this to me um
so you feel this way
no i didn't tell you i felt about it i
told you today this guy was blue in los
angeles i did not tell you wow i feel
really great or horrible that this guy
was blue this guy's blue so it's like
gaslighting and they do it individually
and cult members cult structural
societies what they mistake is that they
you know in the movies and and i grew up
in one i would know i have like a phd in
that
but how i diagnose it
in the us i'll take that as my test
model
is that you know where they always get
it wrong in films literature this and
that is that it's portrayed as like the
svengali where everyone's just kind of
nodding and it goes about in their
drone-like way it's not quite like that
there is the you know the authoritarian
but then it's up to every single member
of every single micro or macro to cross
hypnotize at all times and if one person
say me say you say larry elder say the
punk weirdo that's like yelling truth
from under a bridge whoever you listen
to stands up and is like no
we're not having this you know what is
true and you you just say it and you
take it on the chin for saying it if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell